este vertedero ubicado en youtube en el
occidente de alemania acogerá pronto los
restos de una central nuclear vecina y
normalmente los desechos minerales que
no son entregados aterrizan en este
basurero 3000 toneladas de desechos de
construcción reactivos de muy poca
actividad según las autoridades pero no
contaban con la resistencia de la
dirección y de los habitantes de la
región a málaga claramente hay un
problema de aceptación de la población
que está en todas las inquietudes
relativas a la radioactividad de dichos
desechos
hay estudios que demuestran con el uso
de los desechos de poca actividad son
peligrosos sobre todo que este vertedero
debe cerrar sus puertas en el 2030 y
transformarse en parque público para los
vecinos no es aceptable vivir sobre los
restos de una central nuclear este
colectivo ciudadano protesta
regularmente contra el proyecto
agricultores jubilados militares a favor
del medio ambiente todos unidos por la
misma causa tengo miedo por mí por mis
hijos sabemos que algunas cosas que no
son presentadas como inofensivas
consecuencias en 20 años lo sabemos en
especial en la agricultura
nuestro objetivo es que dichos desechos
sean conducidos a un vertedero
especializado en productos peligrosos o
aún mejor que permanezcan en situ a 30
kilómetros de aquí sobra espacio
alrededor de la central nuclear que está
siendo desmantelada los reactores biblis
fueron desconectados en 2017 en el marco
del abandono de la energía nuclear
iniciado en alemania tras la catástrofe
de fukushima en 2006 un centro de
almacenamiento temporal para desechos
radioactivos fue construido entonces
para los vecinos del vertedero la
solución es evidente para todos los
desechos radioactivos ya sean de poca
mediana o fuerte intensidad deberían ser
almacenados aquí a la espera de una
solución permanente deberíamos haber
empezado a ocuparnos de ello hace 40
años lo que no se hizo y ahora nos dice
lo lamentamos no hay tiempo entonces
vamos a dispersar dichos desechos a lo
largo del país eso no es una solución la
cndh de esta falsa vida porque ese es
justamente el problema alemania aún no
dispone de centro de almacenamiento
definitivo los desechos radioactivos de
mediana o fuerte intensidad están
actualmente almacenados en 16 centros
temporales en superficie la mayoría
ubicados cerca de las centrales
nucleares que están siendo desmanteladas
o que serán desactivadas muy pronto 27
mil toneladas de desechos altamente
radioactivos y 623 mil metros cúbicos de
desechos medianamente o pocos
radioactivos que se acumularán de aquí
al 2 mil 80 tras haber sido considerada
durante mucho tiempo como zonas de
enterramiento definitivo gorleben fue
retirado de la lista en 2020
stanford examina de allá no estaba para
extraer sal sino para desechos altamente
radioactivos por la obstinación de los
antinucleares tales como vulgar en que
acabó con este proyecto pero aquí
también se vive con un centro de
almacenamiento temporal que alberga a
113 castores contenedores de desechos
altamente radioactivos una bomba de
tiempo según él
estos containers envejecen y no sabemos
cuánto tiempo serán herméticos además
este lugar debería estar protegido
contra las catástrofes civiles tales
como accidentes aéreos o contra
atentados terroristas ahora aquí se
puede sobrevolar
en la región de gorleben ha habido
manifestaciones durante decenios para
proteger contra el enterramiento de los
desechos radioactivos en la mina de sal
un lugar reconocido como inadaptado pero
la región sigue en la mira de las
autoridades que se vieron hasta el 2031
para identificar un lugar de
enterramiento definitivo desde hacía 4
subsuelos de arcilla de la región son
considerados como potenciales lugares de
enterramiento de los desechos
radioactivos
por lo tanto esto sigue
la búsqueda de un lugar continúa y
esperamos que esta vez el proceso será
conducido con base en criterios
científicos bien según un primer informe
más de la mitad del territorio alemán
responde a los criterios geológicos
exigidos es decir que cuenta con sus
suelos de sal granito o arcilla pero
según este experto independiente la
identificación la construcción y el
transporte de los desechos radioactivos
a un centro de enterramiento podría
durar hasta el 2090 mientras que los
centros temporales tienen una duración
de vida de 40
alrededor de las centrales nucleares se
creía que iban a cerrar y que todo iba a
desaparecer al cabo de 10 años
nos estamos dando cuenta que eso no
ocurrirá tal como francia alemania sigue
buscando un centro de almacenamiento
definitivo y hoy en día nos damos cuenta
que es urgente
a finales del 2022 a alemania no contará
con ninguna central nuclear activa pero
la búsqueda de un lugar seguro para los
desechos radioactivos producidos por
alemania tras 60 años de explotación
sigue más vigente que nunca